hey guys Ryan right here Brady price so
Brandi I just made her watch don't hug
me I'm scared part 1 and don't hug me
I'm scared part 2 and I told her she
should put up a reaction on her channel
to which she has done now so check out
that video right away I'm leading her
into don't hug me I'm scared part 3
mm-hmm I don't know why I'm so out of
breath don't hug me I'm scared
creepy [ __ ] videos they really
creeped me out the first time I saw them
yeah it was kind of good yes it is
pretty gross there's something about it
that is haunting cuz it lures you win
with like this childlike wonder and then
anything Troy's you I will in and
they're also very sweet at first
yeah he just goes like oh I'll over your
innocence the second one I thought was
trying a little too hard so I think I
think this one I'm hoping it feels
organic that's the word we're looking
for today organic yeah like Whole Foods
oh [ __ ] this is six minutes really yeah
isn't it nice to finally be outside on
such a beautiful day yes and I packed us
a delicious chicken mixes he seems upset
about something I wonder what will
happen it makes you sense doesn't it hmm
but there's so much hatred in the world
I hope you don't mind if I ask you a
question
a little baby pigeon
what's it about you and everyone would
look or you see is hatred and darkness
there for anything but you know it
doesn't have to be I hate you and you
hate me cause even though it different
it doesn't make a difference and we can
live in harmony you don't know who I am
and together we can understand oh I feel
tingly yes that's not my friend and it's
time for you to older
I would love to be on drugs right now
feel like like something everybody hates
you and no one cares but if you follow
me maybe you will see but love is
everywhere what is love is it in the sky
no because I'm hungry
no you're lonely I can see it in your
eyes I don't understand don't worry you
will soon come make some of my friends
they know all about love
come on just over the rainbow look there
he goes flying through the sky maybe we
should follow him
we'll get left behind yes lots of
chicken left
I'd like to eat the chicken I'd also
like to eat the jr. let's do that
instead so here we are with all my
friends and they duck you all of them
yes we do digit is true love you I love
you too baby boy what to do maybe we
should look for a friend isn't that what
friends do and we have finished the
chicken picnic to love each other is to
care to be kind to share I love my words
what if look old compared to the new
because we love you so much
and I'm my pet turkey crap I love this
tree and I love this dish no no that's
how it's done
you must save your your special one
special one everyone has a special one
oh yes it's true but do not worry you're
confused but that's okay let me put it
another way
this is the story of Michael the EE is
for you Todd this is the story of
Michael the ugliest boy in time of the
week
Michael didn't think signatories of the
families of those on the ground you see
everyone has a special one I would
Michael your heartbeat are like a thing
love drum calling for your special one
so be patient because you're my weight
will army made the head shoot for any
perfect it's pure and it's protected
with a brain like a flower it grows and
grows we all worship
thanks Malcolm is the king of love
we were spoon - oh [ __ ] is going on
right now please I am NOT able to keep
up this is your chance to start here and
over asking here to exchange your nerve
anything you and your jardin borda fool
okay now wear this ring you will never
be alone
oh there you are
we've been looking for you all afternoon
we're sorry we upset you but yuck
we bought in the last boiled egg to
cheer you up
I guess it must be because we love you
this pretty be
okay Brotherhood's um yeah okay it was a
little different it's more of a drug
trip than it was like a like random
violent terror that occurs at the end
although I would have liked to have seen
that again
it was I don't know it's so weird
because they're like love is awesome and
then they're like no we worship this God
and if you want to and I don't maybe
it's like a plan the Christianity thing
I have no idea
Gianna T like no because that is the
thought you gathered everybody watching
listen listen listen because they have
the whole that's like the God is love
yes and instead they're saying love is a
god mice Malcolm was the God but they're
refraining him and he's scared of it I
don't have no idea I have no idea it's
so weird I don't think it's meant to be
an Allah I don't eat I don't think so
either I think my analytical mind has
been a little bonkers right now yeah um
honestly this video kind of made me feel
a little stupid cuz I couldn't tell if I
if it didn't make logical sense at all
or if I was just too dumb to keep up
with it all information happen after a
while I was like I don't even know how
we got here like I am so lost maybe
that's why my analytical mind is
analyzing each of the details exactly
exactly
this is one this one [ __ ] with your
brain guys man and it [ __ ] with your
brain gets you thinking it's like the
matrix but for YouTube ya know it's kind
of like the matrix no it's not like the
matrix a lot like the matrix
nobody is oh babe did is
the did its job it was creepy didn't
make any [ __ ] sense
yeah don't hug me I'm scared the
franchise continues to live on mm-hmm I
guess I'm looking forward to part four
yeah I was wondering why they said um
don't hug me
the whole tempeh this was the first
video they'd actually said don't want me
you haven't seen shrek is love shrek is
life have you no I don't know that I
want to see them I might make you watch
it I don't I might know because I think
there should be a crossover between
shrek is love shrek is life and don't
hug me I'm scared I think a raping ogre
who murders people and this combined
both kind of children's tales
to one violent sexual themed video would
be fantastic
watch what do you guys think I'm gonna
pitch to these channels no I don't want
to do it okay I mean if you I mean if
you say money that means I'm gonna make
a lot of money money no I know that was
the accent I was doing yet money muslima
make me some money
oh you oh my god the cycle of me again
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
with this cool annotation up here that
says something interesting
just like fullscreen suggested I do
multi-channel network they're awesome
they're pretty popular yeah that's very
part of the big leagues now you can also
check out Brandis channel she has her
first two videos up and some other crap
I have other crap other crap that's
really sweet of him mm-hmm and um it's
mostly crap well at least you said it
for me thanks MA
but L so this is just check out um the
[ __ ] more my videos there you go my
videos I'm in his videos that accent
doesn't make any logical sense in a
moment you do that it's not like a voice
you do it's like you're putting on an
actual like weird type of European
accent that it's not but it's not
Romanian orison I don't think that it's
a real accent it's just one that I've
fabricated in my own mind maybe I have
my own country in my imagination that
would be cool and they play songs like
this Vicki gah
ha ha ha subscribe porfavor I don't know
what any of this says see me lo penis in
espanol me subscribe oh otra vez
ja ja great video in the shoutouts Josh
I don't know what accent I am doing now
I can't really funny Congrats I guess
she wants to shout out Vicki
C shut out though that's Italian that's
not Spanish
ok xx pack skills X Ryan you need to
reacts with vendors Infini war teaser
trailer I'm waiting for a good quality
video to come out to be honest give me a
shout out you know you want to double X
pack skills X uh yeah yeah I I want to
give you a shout out that is actually a
personal trainer
oh that makes sense because if you do
the xpac it's like ten pack yeah ten
well actually it's a package that is
like cross Packer blood all right huh
it's easy enough yeah well sorry I guess
he drools member Rob you gotta agree
he's so he's so ripped that it's an X
instead of an H so it's not really an a
just like well Roman numeral two apex
you know yeah but sideways yeah huh I
like it I like this I like this shout
out yeah me so x-pac I'm trying to
figure out a way to bring you back in ex
back expect skills get skills yeah you
got you got skills in there multiplying
mm-hmm
Emma Carragher Cara her hey I've been
watching the show for a good while now
and would love a shout out I love the
show Emma you are one of the few females
who actually watches this channel
why what are you doing this is not meant
for woman I mean that was a pretty loud
slapping Emma love slap cuz this chest
to go over here it's been pumping
chesticles pumping yeah he's out of rub
chemicals fun well it makes sense now by
Emma would subscribe because of the
awesome chesticles that's right yeah see
sex appeal number one key taking in the
ladies oh technical mmm Eddie get the
babies recover yeah that's right I can
make my testicles bounce wife Oh God Oh
testicles it's for you Emma that's for
you and Bernie Shabbas you commented
that you wanted a us to watch this video
so there we did it